à mes côtés ce soir en plateau Ziad
l'imam bonsoir bonsoir merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation vous êtes un
habitué vous êtes le directeur de la
revue Jeune Afrique
Magazine et ben voilà vous m'avez mis à
jour face à vous Bruno Darou bonsoir
Bruno bonsoir chroniqueur international
ici à France 24 deux visages que vous
connaissez bien je vous cite donc le
chancelier allemand aujourd'hui Olaf
scholls la France et l'Allemagne reste
très proche et relève les défis ensemble
on notera que les deux hommes ne se sont
pas exprimés publiquement à pas de prise
de parole à la sortie de cette entretien
beaucoup de points divergence on l'a dit
Bruno déjà quels sont-ils et est-ce que
la réunion d'aujourd'hui peut permettre
de faire avancer les choses entre Paris
et Berlin d'abord il faut noter que
cette réunion elle a été organisée un
peu en catastrophe entre le chancelier
et le président suite à l'annulation
d'un conseil des ministres
franco-allemand aujourd'hui même
d'ailleurs il était prévu pour le 26
aujourd'hui et donc il a été annulé les
allemand plus officiellement c'est pour
des raisons logistiques enfin le fait
que ce genre de conseil n'est pas lieu
déjà symboliquement c'est assez lourd et
de manière plus pratique ça sert aussi
ça servait je sais pas comment dire le
présent l'imparfait à Paris et Berlin de
se mettre d'accord sur les points à
l'ordre du jour du prochain sommet
européen donc là déjà ce sera pas le cas
devant les mois provoquer par cette
annulation donc il y a eu ce déjeuner de
travail c'est comme ça que ça a été
présenté organisé en très manuel Macron
et Olaf Scholt à l'issue de laquelle
effectivement il n'y a pas eu de
conférence de presse est-ce que c'est
rare bah c'est rare il y a toujours au
moins une prise de parole sur le perron
même si c'est assez court finalement on
l'a fait avant quand on n'a pas envie de
parler après oui mais là rien du tout on
a juste vu voilà le chancelier accueilli
à son arrivée et ensuite il y a eu des
communiqués un peu un peu classiques en
termes diplomatique quand on vous dit
qu'une réunion a été amicale est
constructive c'est en général soit il ne
s'est pas passé grand chose soit ça a
été un peu plus tendu que ce qu'on
annonce donc je ne suis pas persuadé que
cette rencontre aura permis de débloquer
quand même les dossiers de tension entre
Paris et Berlin qui commence un peu
quand même à s'accumuler on va y revenir
Ziad on a l'impression que Emmanuel
Macron n'a pas trouvé en olafolf le
successeur rêvé dans Gala Merkel c'est
moins qu'on puisse dire
déjà
entre la fiole c'est Angela Merkel on a
deux enfin deux personnages totalement
différents une chancelière Merkel qui
était très impliquée qui qui se montrait
qui parlait qui s'exprimait à nos
lascioles ce qui est qui est taiseux et
très Germano centrée en fait si on lit
un peu ce qui se dit dans la presse
allemande et puis personne n'a prévu
enfin personne ne pouvait imaginer la
guerre et je pense que là il s'est la
guerre qui fait que tout bouge en fait
tout toutes les positions habituelles
un véritable choc traumatique une
redéfinition de sa puissance une
redéfinition de la manière dont elle
dont elle s'est rendu riche parce
qu'elle s'est rendu riche aussi parce
qu'elle avait accès à du gaz qui était
pas cher à de l'énergie politique la
hausse politique le l'alliance plus ou
moins affichée avec la Russie il faut
trouver un nouveau modèle aujourd'hui
pour le l'Allemagne elle elle est
perturbée elle est à la recherche d'un
nouveau modèle la France est perturbée
parce que son partenaire est à la
recherche d'un nouveau modèle et la
France est fragile donc on a aussi du
mal à suivre quand les Allemands
annoncent 200 milliards de subventions
pour l'énergie CTR pour l'énergie le
point est important les 200 milliards
c'est valable pour tout le monde les
privés et les entreprises donc forcément
ça perturbe le marché européen ça
perturbe les données ce qui choque les
Français et pas que les Français on
branlent pas dans deux secondes c'est
qu'il y a pas de concertation c'est fait
tout seul donc on a l'impression d'une
Allemagne qui se referme sur elle-même
et c'est aussi une Allemagne qui est
fragile parce que elle est contestée
comme la France sur sa politique en
Ukraine et les contestée son est on dit
que l'Allemagne est le pivot mais en
réalité l'est de l'Europe nous comment
dire méprise mais bon nous nous secoue
assez brutalement sur le dossier
ukrainien les Polonais les pays baltes
voilà tous ces gens
l'Allemagne n'est pas populaire en ce
moment en Union Européenne et je pense
qu'en France on est bien conscient que
que ça soit pour des dossiers bilatéraux
ou que ça soit pour la sauvegarde
européenne il faut qu'on reconstruise ce
lien et moi je trouve quand même que le
choix des mots d'aujourd'hui même si toi
et moi on a l'habitude des des mots
diplomatiques mais amicales et
constructif je pense que ça veut dire on
reste amis et constructif je pense que
ça a été rock n' roll mais l'intérêt
l'intérêt fondamental de maintenir le
lien je pense que les deux côtés c'est
c'est assumé sur le fond Bruno qu'est-ce
qui bloque est-ce que c'est un problème
technique c'est un problème politique
est-ce que c'est les deux
en fait ce qui bloque donc il y a
plusieurs dossiers un peu précis qui
bloque alors il y a d'abord eu l'annonce
de ce plan de 100 milliards de 200
milliards donc sans concertation ça à
Paris et pas seulement qu'à Paris
effectivement c'est pas le même passé du
tout après effectivement la guerre en
Ukraine fait que toute se redéfinie un
peu et que ça permet ce que peut-être
l'Allemagne n'attendait pas comme ça
mais en fait cet événement permet à
l'Allemagne non seulement d'être un
géant économique ce qui lui donne
d'ailleurs quand même pour le moment un
avantage considérable par rapport à un
pays comme la France mais ça c'était
déjà le cas c'était déjà acquis mais de
redevenir aussi une puissance importante
sur le plan militaire puisque
l'Allemagne clairement a annoncé qu'elle
va débloquer 100 milliard d'euros pour
moderniser son armée et du coup sur le
plan politique et ça inquiète à Paris
parce que jusqu'ici en fait le coup
franco-allemand bon ça pas toujours été
non plus la lune de miel il y a eu des
périodes de tension etc mais
l'importance du lien était toujours
affirmer mais ça reposait sur un sur un
équilibre en quelque sorte bon
l'Allemagne c'était l'économie la France
était le militaire la diplomatie là avec
la guerre en Ukraine tout est un peu
déséquilibré et au cas des deux pays ne
sait trop comment se situer et en tout
cas l'Allemagne elle a des fragilités
aussi mais à la de l'argent à la pour le
moment beaucoup d'argent et elle se dit
que dans 10-15 ans les perspectives ne
sont pas toutes brillantes pour elle
donc en attendant le protège ses
entreprises elle débloque ses milliards
et elle fait effectivement elle suit ses
intérêts un peu au détriment de l'Union
européenne et du lien avec la France
sans quand même effectivement aller trop
loin mais il a fallu quand même
qu'Emmanuel Macron ce qui est rare dise
publiquement je me souviens plus des
termes exacts qu'il employé mais que là
ça n'allait pas avec l'Allemagne c'est
peut-être pour ça ce qui a déclenché ce
déjeuné là les Allemands sont peut-être
dit bon il faut quand même effectivement
maintenir ce lien d'abord ce sont nos
principaux partenaires commerciaux même
si il y en a d'autres concernant les
Allemands et c'est aussi ça d'ailleurs
qui préoccupe les Allemands au passage
d'un point de vue économique c'est que
leur modèle qui était une énergie très
faible gaz russe et puis des
exportations qui lui assurer ces
excellents commerciaux ce modèle il est
en train un peu de de quoi et la
conséquence de tout ça Ziad c'est un
couple franco-allemand qui bat de l'aile
ça peut donner peut-être des idées à
d'autres pays européens de sortir de
cette férule justement du coup
franco-allemand de trouver un autre
modèle pour eux aussi peut-être le
problème c'est que certes sortir du coup
franco-allemand mais pourquoi faire
c'est-à-dire que si vous regardez par
exemple l'Europe de l'Est et les pays
baltes à part de dire il faut faire la
guerre en Ukraine il y a pas il y a pas
d'initiative européenne particulièrement
intéressante il faut quand même pas
négliger le poids de l'Allemagne et de
la France réunis c'est quand même le le
le moteur économique à défaut d'être
amoureux ils peuvent compter leurs sous
ensemble et je pense aussi que le fait
aussi que cette guerre réintroduit les
États-Unis dans le jeu européen que ça
soit via l'OTAN que ça soit via les
programmes d'armement que les Allemands
sont tentés d'ailleurs
d'acheter américain plutôt que d'acheter
français tout ça et puis et tout ça est
une énorme perturbation mais que au fond
au fond on sait que ce qu'on peut perdre
et beaucoup plus important que ce qu'on
peut gagner et je pense aussi que chez
les Allemands il faut jamais oublier
qu'ils ont une politique intérieure ils
ont une coalition fragile et qu'il faut
défendre ce gouvernement parce que s'il
de même s'il venait à se casser la
figure aussi c'est pas exclu donc voilà
donc on joue sur les œufs les messages
sont assez musclés comme tu l'as dit de
la part de la France mais je pense que
l'Allemagne est isolé aussi elle n'a pas
d'allier en ce moment et elle peut pas
elle peut pas gouverner cette Europe ou
imposer sa puissance sans fonctionner
avec des alliances donc bon on peut
lâcher 200 milliards mais demain ce
qu'on fait donc je pense que à la fin
c'est un peu comme les États-Unis et
l'Arabie saoudite à la fin ont fini
toujours par trouver quelque chose qui
permet d'avancer
ça permet quand même ce qui sera
peut-être pas le cas c'est pour ça que
les autres pays sont furieux à
l'Allemagne et aux entreprises
allemandes de traverser la tempête ce
qui sera peut-être pas le cas des
entreprises en France ou dans d'autres
pays de l'Union européenne ce qui va
permettre l'Allemagne et là ça c'est une
constante quand même de la politique
allemande au sein de l'Union européenne
quand on regarde les différents épisodes
c'est de préserver sa domination
économique sur le reste du continent
mais il faut des subventions mais il
faut des clients c'est pour ça
alors c'est pour ça qu'il y a d'autres
clients que les clients européens les
Chinois confièrent ce qui s'est passé
quand même aujourd'hui alors l'Allemagne
a au port d'Hambourg voilà le port de
Hambourg bon alors finalement il sait
non pas 35% mais un peu moins de 25% ce
qui veut dire que ce n'est pas une
participation stratégique des Chinois
qui donc en principe n'ont pas leur mot
à dire sur ça mais effectivement ça fait
beaucoup jaser en Europe que l'Allemagne
après sa dépendance à la Russie se
mettent continuent être dans une forme
de dépendance autogène que controversée
avec la Chine se jette en quelque sorte
dans les bras chinois après les bras
russes le message est passé allez on
passe au second thème le chat payant
crise je dis dernier a été un jeudi noir
pour le pays la répression des
manifestants antipouvoirs a fait une
cinquantaine de morts selon un bilan
officiel d'autres sources évoquent un
bilan bien plus lourd depuis hier un
sommet extraordinaire des pays d'Afrique
centrale consacré à cette situation se
tient à Kinshasa je vous propose
d'écouter Félix Tshisekedi nommé
facilitateur dans ce dossier
comme vous le savez il s'agit d'une
lourde responsabilité et je peux d'ores
et déjà vous rassurer que je ne
ménagerai aucun effort pour remplir
cette noble mission pour l'avènement et
le maintien de la paix
il y a donc deux camps celui du
président
notamment amenée par les transformateurs
on a le sentiment d'y être d'une rupture
consommée ça fait longtemps qu'on
n'avait pas vu une telle rupture au
Tchad ou pas c'est votre sentiment moi
je pense qu'on est dans une continuité
de multiples ruptures et de fractures de
multiples rupture et de fractures
multiples le dialogue qui se devait
d'être inclusif finalement c'est quand
même résumé un dialogue du parti au
pouvoir de la mouvance présidentielle et
de ses alliés plus ou moins
affichées et donc il y a eu un point de
rupture majeure qui était la question de
savoir est-ce que le prolonguement le
prolongement de la transition et la
question de savoir est-ce que les
militaires
quitter le pouvoir et en sous-titrage
est-ce que le président débit fils
allait pouvoir se représenter ou pas et
je pense que la clé de cette histoire
c'est le fait que ça c'est
rester dans le flou et donc il y a une
possibilité pour les militaires et le
fils des billes de rester au pouvoir
mais les fractures sont multiples il y a
une fracture entre au sein de ces de ce
Nord entre les différents groupes les
différentes familles entre les touboules
et les Goranes les gens proches du clan
des billes les gens contre le y compris
dans sa propre famille donc il y a un or
qui est en permanence en ébullition en
compétition de pouvoir il y a un Sud qui
se sent marginalisés qui se sont exclus
depuis des décennies du pouvoir central
de ne jamais na et qui a un leader qui
succès se massera qui les
transformateurs qui finalement incarnent
toutes ces
cette envie de ces élites du sud de
retrouver une place et puis il y a les
mouvements armés qui n'ont pas à cédé il
y a des mouvements à la frontière
libyenne il y a ce triangle Libye Niger
Tchad qui est un lieu de toutes les de
tous les trafics d'or d'armes etc et
donc et il y a enfin un dernier point
qui est la mauvaise humeur de la France
je pense qui est quand même le garant de
tous les régimes successifs et en tous
les cas qui a sauvé la peau de
Idriss Déby un certain nombre de fois et
je pense qu'il y a eu des échanges assez
clair entre la présidence française et
la présidente chadienne sur le fait
qu'il devait y avoir réellement une
transition et non pas un maintien des
mites au pouvoir donc on a tous les
facteurs d'une crise qui peuvent aller
qui peut aller loin et je ne pense pas
que la médiation de Kinshasa oui parce
que le problème est tchadien avant tout
Bruno est-ce qu'il y a des motifs
d'espoir aujourd'hui au chat selon vous
que le dialogue est auparavant et puis
et puis les victimes et puis quand même
beaucoup de victimes je crois 50 morts
officiellement mais c'est officiellement
effectivement et puis alors le
l'intervention
de ma maty brise les billes n'a pas du
tout calmé les choses en fait il y a de
parler de fractures il a chargé de
l'opposition c'est-à-dire que en fait
c'est effectivement comme assez souvent
visiblement l'armée voilà qui veut
continuer à se maintenir au pouvoir qui
ne respecte pas les termes de la
transition finalement puisque la
transition est prolongée de deux ans et
qui dans la modalité la transition
finalement n'inclut pas du tout les
oppositions et la société civile donc
oui on est dans une forme de non
dialogue ce qui fait que effectivement
la situation reste quand même
extrêmement préoccupante les deux
parties ont été suspendues on le
rappelle les deux parties d'opposition
Ziad comment sont traités aujourd'hui
les opposants les voies dissonantes au
Tchad on peut encore être opposant
là-bas mais est-ce qu'on est-ce qu'on la
gère est-ce qu'on l'a déjà été le Tchad
c'est c'est ça peut peut-être faire
rouler certaines personnes pour moi ça
ça ressemble au Soudan dans dans le dans
le dans la géographie dans la dans la
dans la coupure dans on a fêté le
premier anniversaire de l'arrivée des
militaires au pouvoir d'ailleurs hier
oui mais il y a aussi la naissance du
Soudan du Sud et je pense qu'il ne faut
pas exclure de manière arbitraire dans
l'avenir des redécoupages importants
d'un certain nombre de pays ou deux
zones parce que le pro les problèmes de
fonds sont pas réglés encore une fois il
y a toutes ces fractures là qui existent
qu'on connaît et qu'on dont on n'arrive
pas à donner une réponse politique
la réponse politique ça serait
probablement de passer par les unes mais
ça ne changerait pas fondamentalement il
faudrait quelqu'un d'un petit peu
exceptionnel je dis pas ça pour les uns
pour les autres pour donner une
impulsion de rassemblement et de il y a
tellement de blessures il y a tellement
de l'historicité il y a tellement de les
victimes de des derniers jours c'est
quand même des dizaines de familles qui
sont ennuyés donc il faut être
extrêmement prudent sur l'évolution du
pays à court terme et je vous propose
justement d'écouter un extrait de
l'intervention du président tchadien
c'était lundi à la télévision
dans notre passé récent
les intervenants extérieurs ont fournis
armes
et donner de l'argent à des Tchadiens
opportuniste qui n'ont pas hésité un
seul instant à détruire notre pays pour
satisfaire leur intérêt personnel
Bruno intérêt personnel agent de
l'extérieur c'est le message envoyé par
le président tchadien oui bah ce que je
disais il y a quelques minutes en fait
il a pas du tout été dans la
conciliation etc il a désigné non
seulement les mouvements d'opposition
mais là il le dit pas dans l'extrait
qu'on vient de passer mais le groupe
rebelle fact d'être
tous ces gens-là sur le menu se sont
coalisés pour essayer de même peut-être
de renverser l'état donc pas du tout une
transition apaisée qui se profile merci
beaucoup messieurs d'avoir participé à
cette émission merci Ziad merci Bruno
quelques minutes de pause quatre minutes
et l'information revient sur notre
antenne à tout de suite